it was awesome being a miami at that
time
you know south beach was was was popping
i mean like
how much [ __ ] were you getting at the
time in life like you
i mean listen you're in miami i mean by
the way your college had to be crazy
college college was crazy i'm more of a
uh
quality quality over quantity i mean i
love a quantity of quality
quantity what's the highest amount of
quantity of quality you've had at once
uh at once just three but in like a day
before some
seven so you had three girls and you
three and me yeah oh so fast
time but but in a day probably seven so
in in miami yeah cause it might
i it's miami it's just it's just such a
sexy city like
every time i go down there i can't help
it i just love going to tootsies man
i mean i love tootsies i got
i bet you she's like i've ran in and out
of that place
vip's 400 bucks anyway um
wait wait what's it wait wait how old
were you had your foursome
that's kind of that's a moment in life
this was right out of right out of um
right out of college so this is when i
was in i was single i was in new orleans
a rookie i had a big-ass house just
running it up
yeah we yeah you know i mean i don't
want to like
you know seven in a day too that's
impressive
yes you know that's just being done
that's just being dumb and
flexing your muscle you know you had to
be on hypertrophy
if you're [ __ ] seven girls in a day
you gotta be on something you gotta be
on some hydroxy cut or some of that [ __ ]
you were talking about that your full
back was on
that's impressive at the most i did two
in a day
you know in my heyday seven is
you know but that's like what groupies
why when there's people that that are
called groupies
it's easy it's easy right it's easy it's
harder to say no
at some points than it is to say yes